Football season is upon us, and apparently,
this means it's time to talk politics.
I wish we could separate sports and politics,
or pretty much everything and politics, but
somehow politics has infected every facet
of American life.
Inserting politics into virtually everything
we consume is a really bad sign as to what
direction this country is heading.
That isn't to deny the feelings of the players
who take the knee, but it is to acknowledge
why people watch sports in the first place.
People turn to sports, video games, and other
entertainment to escape politics and the cold
hard realities of life.
Now, it seems everywhere you turn, politics
has reared its ugly head.
If you don't take a side and scream about
it, or at least tweet about it, then you'll
be tossed in as racist or anti American, depending
on who is leveling the charge.
When our momentary escapes from reality...like
sports... are taken away from us in exchange
for more political fighting, we should all
take a step back and asses what's really going
on here.
OK, so let's start with Trump.
Trump kicked this whole controversy off on
Friday night at a speech in Alabama where
he said that NFL owners should get rid of
players who don't stand for the national anthem,
saying "Get that son of a bitch off the field
right now, he's fired.
He's fired!"
Now let me be crystal clear here: calling
a football player, or any other citizen a
son of a bitch under any circumstances is
not the type of language I'd like to hear
from the highest office in the land.
As a free speech supporter, I do have major
concerns about the chill factor around free
speech when the president makes comments like
this.
Personally, I'd much rather have a president
who could share his own personal beliefs on
a matter, while still affirming the right
of every citizen to protest, while and also
acknowledging private companies can tend to
their employees however they see fit.
That's how this exchange is supposed to work
in a free society.
The president can say whatever he wants, the
football players can do whatever they want,
the teams can respond as they see fit -- and
you, too, can use your voice to share your
feelings on it all.
So again, to be clear here, even if Trump
isn't saying or tweeting statements just as
I'd like him to, he has the exact same right
to free speech the rest of us have.
Now, if he tried to instruct federal agencies
to punish players or football teams teams
for exercising their right to free speech,
we would have an illegal act and an impeachable
offense.
As far as I can see, he didn't do that, though
he did intentionally inflame the situation
by getting as close to seeming to use government
authority to silence people without quite
doing so.
Understanding that Trump said something, but
didn't sign an executive action on it is an
important distinction though, because words
are not action, even when those words are
uttered by the president of the United States.
And it's worth mentioning that these protests
started under Obama, so while Trump has added
fuel to the fire, the seeds of these protests
had already been planted.
Now onto the players.
It is 100% within the players right to exercise
their free speech as they say fit.
While I personally would never kneel during
the national anthem, it is completely within
their right to do so.
And for those of you who think kneeling during
the anthem is unamerican, or not the player's
right to do so, imagine for a moment what
kind of country you'd be living in if people
couldn't protest peacefully.
You may think that these players are misguided
or mistaken, but imagine the society we'd
be living in if the government could force
people to stand for our national anthem.
What else could the government force us to
do against our will once we've given it that
power?
Of course, the players exercising their right
to free speech must understand that their
actions might have consequences as well.
This is the implicit exchange we all must
make to live in a truly free society.
NFL teams can fine or suspend players as they
see fit, and nobody has an inherent right
to play in the NFL.
By the way, nobody has in inherent right to
work at Google either, but I didn't see many
of the people who are standing up the players
right now also stand up for fired Google engineer
James Damore when he voiced his opinion on
Google's diversity program.
Interestingly, Damore was fired for doing
exactly what the company had asked him to
do....attend a diversity course and then share
his opinions on it.
So to recap, Trump can say what he wants as
long as he doesn't use his government influence
to silence people, players can do what they
want knowing there could be repercussions,
and teams can deal with players however they
see fit.
So now onto you, the public.
If football fans don't want to buy tickets
or watch the games because of the protests,
well at the end of the day, even the great
American pastime of football is just a business
-- owners and management have the right and
the duty to do what's best for their business.
If nobody is buying tickets, watching on the
games on TV, or buying merchandise, then there
will be nobody to see the protests in the
first place.
This is the beauty of capitalism.
Everyone from the president to the owners
to the players to the fans all have the ability
to exercise their speech as they see fit.
And if their speech isn't enough to make a
dent in a cause they believe in then they
can still support a cause, or not, with their
hard earned dollars.
This is freedom actually working right in
front of our eyes and virtually all of the
media is making it seem like this is the end
of civilization.
If you stand with Colin Kapernick and the
other players, then feel free to boycott the
NFL.
If you don't like the American flag being
disrespected by the players, then boycott
the NFL.
I'd rather just watch some football, or in
my case basketball, but you have the capacity
and right to do whatever you want.
To be very clear: I 100% stand by these players
doing whatever to protest or not if that's
what their conscience tells them to do.
I also stand by their employers to do what
they feel is right for their business even
if I don't agree with it, and I do not want
the government to pass any law which would
impeded on the rights of the players or any
sports organization.
This position doesn't deny anyone's grievances
or feelings, it actually maximizes personal
responsibility which is the cornerstone of
a free society.
Like I said before, while I'd love politics
out of sports and sports out of politics,
it now seems that our president and our media
isn't going to let this seperation happen.
I basically never watch Sports Center anymore
because it's an endless blotter of crime stories
and politics with game highlights tossed in
for good measure.
What those of us who want to respect our fellow
citizens and the law can do, is to discuss
the situtaion within the framework of what
it truly means to be free.
Nobody has been fired because of their speech,
athough Kapernick does remains a free agent...which
goes back to that consequences thing...
no law has been passed to actually silence
anyone, and we all have an equal chance for
our opinion to be heard.
While many would point only to the evils of
our political system, this story is actually
showing the strength of our democracy.
Don't like Trump's statements?
Don't vote for him.
Don't like the players who sat for the anthem?
Don't buy their jersey.
Sick of the whole damn thing?
Find something better to do than drink beer
and watch football on Sundays.
All of the discussion and debate around kneeling
for the anthem and honoring the country is
healthy as long as it doesn't turn into violence
and tyranny.
Calmer heads can win this game as long as
we stand for the principles of free speech
and the right to a peaceful protest, even
when we don't want to.
The second we set aside our principles we're
just picking a political team and rooting
for our side as if it were a football game.
For now, though, I'll pass on picking a team
and remain a free agent in the marketplace
of ideas.